[Music]
welcome back TMS brain health Las Vegas
the sponsors of this segment are making
high quality Mental Health Care
accessible so how can TMS alleviate
mental health symptoms like depression
and anxiety we stop by to learn more
[Music]
my name is Judith lateich and we at a
TMS brain health Las Vegas this is a
clinic in Vegas that treats mental
health disorders especially the
treatment resistant depression we do TMS
tms's transcranial magnetic stimulation
it's an alternative treatment for
depression and it's FDA approved not
only TMS is used for depression we also
use it for anxiety we also use it for
OCD and I've had also good results from
patients that I have done that for so
since we've been practicing TMS here in
Las Vegas I have my patient here as my
testimonial of what we have been doing
and what is the results of TNS what has
TMS been like for you you are one of my
clients that I treated
um for depression and can you tell us
how your results have been
[Music]
it's been amazing it's not like it's a
one-time thing it's it's although I've
been away from it for a few months now I
still feel like I'm getting
progress from it and that's that's an
amazing thing I'm going through a lot of
pain that really wears me out and I
don't think I would be handling it near
as well it's almost more to me like an
Awakening or
literally brain cells that haven't
worked for a long time or starting to
click in that I mean that's how I felt
to me that's really really a good way of
putting it actually because when they
kick in they start connecting together
yeah and that's probably why I feel like
I'm still continually getting better
absolutely it's a very safe method
compared to the side effects that they
get from all these medications that
they've been taking and normally if
there's a side effect it's very mild it
could be something like a minor headache
just because of the stimulation of the
machine on that side and then it's it's
gone it's not something that is lasting
so when you know and you see this
results working for a patient it's
really really profound because I get to
see the patients when they are walking
in through the door very depressed and
when they leave on that sixth week and
they are their symptoms have alleviated
they're like two different people so I
always say I wish I wish I could take a
video of them coming in and a video when
they're leaving and we can compare the
two because their mood is lifted they
they're ready to go back to their lives
some want to go back to school they're
heading back to school some feel like
well this is the wife that I married so
it's really humbling and very rewarding
to see that the good news is TMS is
covered by most insurance most people
have tried the anti-depressant drought
and they've experienced really bad side
effects like some are like insomnia lack
of libido fatigue weight gain so if you
feel like you want to try something
alternative you can give us a call or go
to our website and we will screen you
and see if you do fit to receive TMS
treatment
thank you to TMS brain health Las Vegas
for sponsoring this segment for more
information call
833-867-2329 or visit tmsbrainhealth.com